This morning.
Chilling video
shows a toddler
in Indiana
waving around
and pulling the trigger
of a loaded handgun.
This actually happened on live
television.
Body camera footage shows police
speaking with neighbors
after they discovered the little
And when I opened the door,
he went to flip it up
and I shut the door,
told everyone to get away from t
Like she he was like he has a gu
I mean, it's a toddler in a diap
Is walking around with a handgun
They took you out and now to get
Well, it takes that long for.
No, no, no, no.
I'm talking about the parents up
Jean Casarez,
has been following this story
and joins us now.
How how how.
This is amazing.
All caught on police body cam.
So I just want to take you throu
This is Beech Grove, Indiana.
And what happened
is that the officers
were called to an apartment comp
because of a toddler with a gun.
And so they get there.
And one of the neighbors
is standing right there.
And she begins to tell them,
I saw this toddler.
He was waving around
a gun, a real gun watch
of So my son opened the door
and I saw the boy upstairs
and just stand there with firear
And I looked up people and Steve
went on to say
that she looked through the peop
and there he was, hands behind h
He brings.
And he points.
A guy says, look at what I've go
That's what she said.
So officers go to the apartment.
You're going to watch them
going into the apartment right n
And they said to the father,
We believe your toddler had a gu
That's what they're saying.
We've got a search.
And they searched high
and low in that apartment
to see if they could find any gu
And you watch that.
And they didn't find anything.
Father said there is no gun here
He did say,
you know,
a relative of mine comes
and he leaves a gun every now an
But he said, my son is quick.
I can't catch him all the time.
So officers have to leave.
They don't have a gun.
And so they come back.
They tell the neighbor
we couldn't find the gun.
One of the officers stays back
and she summons them to her iPho
And lo and behold,
she's got ring
video from a neighbor
that shows the toddler in the en
at the apartment complex with a
waving it around, pulling the tr
And so they're looking for it.
Well, they go back to the apartm
there is a gun. Yeah.
And they go in the apartment.
They searched high and low.
They find the gun.
And from my observation of that
they find it in a desk
carefully placed in a desk.
The officer immediately unloads
There were 15 rounds in that gun
but none of them were chambered.
And because of that, as the todd
in diapers
basically was pulling the trigge
it didn't go off.
Father arrested, charged with ne
At this point,
these are arresting charges.
Remember, he said there's no gun
So his state of mind,
maybe he didn't know about the g
However, the way it was placed
where it was,
could the toddler have put it ba
That's going to be a pivotal que
And prosecutors can
add more charges to this